hey everyone
hi hey
uh
let me just get a hold of steve here
he's asking to be let in
okay
great to see you all here
welcome to uh another link gathering
hope everybody's doing well
uh steve has no
picture hang on one second
um oh start my video
all right there we go okay
um
uh
yeah maybe uh the best thing to do is to
get right into it um oh we lost
jade
anyway
um
might be best if if um
we just start and and maybe introduce
yourself and uh
and then uh
go right into your presentation uh ken
it looks like your microphone's active
maybe you can start
okay hi
cam i've been on link
oh i think i started in
2014 so five six years ago though not
very seriously
for the first year and a half or so and
then i
started to do it more regularly i had
started russian
when i was a freshman in high school so
a long time ago
and did well at it i learned the grammar
pretty well
and but like everyone says didn't learn
enough words to do much with it
um always kept an interest in the
language didn't really do much with it
until i picked it up again
started finding more sources on the
internet
that became a thing
um
so so much different than when i started
there were
it was so hard to find sources back then
anything from russia there was there i
think there was one one company that
imported books and magazines and
newspapers from russia to the us at the
time that you could get stuff through
of course you could find some stuff in
books that used book sales and stuff but
it's just made such a
you know when i found i could find all
sorts of russian stuff on on the
internet that's when i started picking
it up again um i did make a trip to
russia to the soviet union actually when
i was
just after i finished high school
behind me is my map my politicians guy
kakamira that i bought in moscow in
1979 i think um
so
since i knew the grammar pretty well my
vocabulary was limited i mostly
have
um
i don't do a whole lot of listening on
link um i i import a lot of stuff that
doesn't have
um
audio um i will listen to anybody who
does russian on link
knows you have guinea
ski yeah i'll watch and listen to any a
lot of his stuff that he puts up that's
interesting but otherwise i mostly just
import stuff
and
big leaps and vocabulary have come from
books when once
you get enough to to get an interesting
book that just
as everybody knows who's tried it it
just brings you
along so much faster and
the um some of the books i've liked that
i've liked so much i've actually went
out and got a hard cover copy of lavre
which i read on link first um just
because it's nice to have something to
hold in your hands
from that era
um
so
the um
i'm going to share my screen real quick
go over how i do some things
just briefly i mean this is our fifth
week of this there's not going to be a
whole lot of new in what you can do but
maybe some of the philosophy you know
about how and why
um
if you can see my screen here
um in russian i won't spend a lot of
time here because probably most of
people can't make any sense of these
letters which is a little bit annoying
um
but
first i'll point out that i don't think
somehow we're not i'm not seeing you're
not seeing anything um okay here the
stair screen button in the middle okay i
selected it but didn't say chair share
there it goes oh okay
okay
so
first thing i do for anybody who's
starting in russian is you might want to
choose the cyrillic
i think the
the serif font because
there's a couple letters that always
um
you know
are hard to pick out sometimes
especially when your eyes are
um tired the l
and the p
um here in shlopu is is
are very similar though with the serif
font
though the weight and the strokes is a
little bit different if you switch over
to the um
standard
font
those look very similar especially when
they're smaller i've
increased the font size here to make a
little bit easier to see when sharing
but
but anyway
um
when i do
reading in russian i
deselect most of these things in the
settings i i let the grammar tagging go
even though i really haven't used that
but the
other things i just want to handle
manually
or whatnot
i always
even if i know the words
i will
high
link and keep linked i won't move to
know
usually
multi-word links phrases because even if
you know the words um prince perez said
yato i know travia i know but it's not
necessarily obvious that together they
mean chairman of the board things like
that um
so
that's about it for russian really some
of the sources i use i i read
my stats on link won't show much
um
at all for listening though i listen for
hours a day on youtube mostly
um
any number of bloggers commentators and
such
um i started
when i started back on russian here my
listening comprehension was nil
so i'm listening on linked help watching
movies bloggers and stuff and even if
you don't understand them
the visuals can grab you you understand
enough of what's going on it's
interesting you tune your ear
and eventually you stop trying to
translate in your head you can just hear
and listen some of the
channels i watch i can understand
everything they say and i just listen
for good i'm listening to russian other
people that i don't know why the
vocabulary the pronunciation it's still
a struggle though but
um
but one thing i noted when i offered to
come on here is that so i've got lots of
russian
i just recently started on german and so
i use it different for german so people
are always asking how do i use link
what's the best way to use link it's um
a lot of it will depend on on what your
you know what your level are what you're
doing and in german i'm you're almost
on the 53rd mini story i always use
sentence mode um
and i'll use the audio
so i can
learn it i
i don't have any of the experience with
the past experience like i had with
russian
and i'll listen to the sentence and i'll
listen to the sentence four or five
times until it sounds natural i can get
the meaning how it's kind of put
together
just just from listening and i'll do
that then i'll go to the next one at the
very end of the lesson i'll review the
links
just a little bit more exposure
familiarity
having just gone through the story i
usually get them all without any problem
and they'll all forget them later but
then after doing that then i'll go
through and i'll
listen to and read the entire story you
you know just follow along in the full
text while the narrator talks
um
just starting in german you see only got
six eighteen used known words and
probably three quarters of those are
cognates it's such a
german is so much nicer after coming
from russian it's like afterwards you
know you kind of put on your
um
uh
yoto vibe to get the
sentence structure and um it's um
it's been fun so far like i'm just
starting
the
it
so much easier to read too even though
i've known the cyrillic alphabet for
decades and
it's very phonetic and easy to
see what a word means it's just
not what you were
doing since you were five years old and
it
it's slow it i cannot not read it as
fast as i can even the german here so
um
so no just a couple other things to
share and i'll turn it over to some
others
i've got
this book
from when i was a sophomore in high
school i think i don't know if this was
my copy if i found one at a used book
sale and got it for nostalgia reason
reasons but it's
a collection of stories and at the
introduction you know says it's a graded
reader it's got um
glosses in in the margin
to to help you with some words that you
might find it's got accent marks on the
words so you can figure out the
pronunciation and as i was looking at
this i was thinking link pretty much
replaces this
lynx has got the graded text you know by
ability it's got the pronunciation it's
got the
glosses right there next to the words if
you need them
um
but this has got some good interesting
stories a number of which i've actually
interrupted it would be easier to see
the book of mormon shared
oh yeah
sharing your screen we can see better
yeah i was holding it up i could see it
but um
the um
so how do i get out of share
i think down same place where you share
it if you if you hover down at the
bottom of the
bottom of the screen
or maybe even at the top
don't know
here we go
view options maybe can somebody take it
away from me maybe
i get it because i'm not seeing
sure
i see i've seen the whole
screen here
yeah is it the sh
ah no it's not the share screen button
at the bottom is it
here it is i found it it's on a
different monitor
oh okay
here's here's the book
um
see it's got the glasses and the margins
and the text it's probably too small to
see it's got the accent marks but like i
was saying um this was great when i was
in school um it's
interesting
the content's interesting but you know
that pretty much everything this offers
you you find on link
as long as you can find the interesting
content there's an awful lot there
one of the stories i particularly
remember even though it was decades ago
actually is a series of stories that
i've actually found online anybody who's
looking for some good low intermediate
level in
on rushing you might search for
papa will malenkin
when papa was little
um
it's a
series of stories and a book by an
author that i've found online
um
they're very very short
he's fairly easy to read interesting um
but anyway another question that comes
fully and related to russian aren't
german a question that comes up
fairly regularly is how do you learn
these foreign scripts
russian arabic or whatever i took a
couple semesters once a week adult
education no grades
easy relax interesting arabic class at
the junior college
before doing that i had gotten this book
and you can find material like this and
any number of books are online this is
specifically the beginner's arabic
script
you know introduces a letter or you know
a few letters a time first chapter six
letters
um
how to write them um how how and when to
join them or not um
and then you know a handful of words
that use them and then the next chapter
adds a few more letters and a few more
words and it goes on that and it's easy
to do it that way i didn't find the
arabic script difficult the russian
script is
easy because it's so phonetic and half
of it's familiar in the half that's not
familiar i never confused
the rfrp
when i'm in cyrillic so
that's probably about all i've got to
share i've got my
german made simple that i picked up
somewhere used a long time ago and never
cracked and i um have my doubts about
the simple part um it's full of grammar
tables and stuff
um
one thing i do online that um
i mentioned in the uh
forums
is um
i like to watch videos one of english
russian language videos
teaching english for some reason i just
find that interesting
to listen to
but also um
there's whoops
i don't want that
the um
polyglot series russian
tv series dimitri petrov
has
a
series about a large number of different
languages and i just like to watch those
hindu um whatever just listen to him
talk about these in russian um
i've watched a number of his
videos about german and i'll probably
watch more he really gets
his introduction to german he talks
about how
a philosophy sounds a whole lot that'll
sound very familiar with folks familiar
with link you know
don't don't stress over the grammar too
much get into it get the content and the
meaning
and then you get some lessons and it's
all grammar tables and stuff but um
after reading going through most of the
mini stories here and seeing a lot of
things that
um seeing some patterns and stuff i'll
probably watch those videos just to
see him cover the tenses and and cases
and stuff
and then so then when i go back and read
more german
when i see those things
it'll click a bit more what exactly am i
seeing it'll help maybe cement those
patterns a little bit more quickly
um
i think i've
yeah i
uh so maybe we'll uh
move on and answer some of them um
very interesting presentation yeah a lot
of stuff there that i know
matches with stuff that i do i mean
certainly
reading books has
i've always found
at least vocabulary wise
leads to massive sort of jumps in your
known words and and ability obviously to
to to understand the language so i
definitely find that um
there there was a question here and i i
and maybe we should we could steve you
may we can have some comments from you
and then we can look at some of these
other questions
you seem to be muted
dude
yeah i mean do we want to uh yeah maybe
i could just make some quick comments
but i'm also looking forward to
listening to the other people here
but certainly as you say lots in um in
ken's presentation that's familiar
including 20 30 years ago scouring
second-hand bookstores here in vancouver
to find
old readers in german or other languages
with the glossaries for each chapter and
lots of pencil scribblings that people
had done and
and all of the sort of before link and
in a way that's almost what inspired us
to get into link
um many stories as well i'm very curious
to hear ken as a beginner in german how
difficult did you find it to jump right
into the mini stories
um not difficult at all
and actually a long time ago in college
i had one half of one semester of german
so i didn't get much
but
there there's
more is familiar than i would have
expected
but even so like i said compared to
russian
it's an entirely different than language
than english obviously but
it's coming from russian is so obviously
related to english
yeah and another comment that i
certainly agree with is like i studied
russian
long many years and i'm much better in
russian than czech but when i got to
read a slavic language in the latin
alphabet it's just so much easier
because as you said you cannot account
you know you can't make up for the fact
that since the age of five you've been
reading in your native alphabet and if
you learn another alphabet it's always
more it's always going to be more
difficult to read in that alphabet
um
so but i'm interested in the mini stores
because i jumped into the many stories
with greek with persian with arabic and
i found that a great place to start like
even though you're jumping into a sort
of a low intermediate level
type of content there's so much
repetition in each mini story the the
same vocabulary and structure basically
repeats five times
and so that uh i find that it's a great
place to start but that's my experience
i'm very interested we'll often get
people that come on and and complain
because they're right into whether it's
mini stories or something some other
beginner text and and
wanting instead to be you know learning
cat dog flower
how are you
mom and um yeah
in fact i think
we always our part of our message always
is just do it just let your brain get
used to it read those sentences and
what's great obviously with the mini
stories is there's
repetition there built into the text so
that uh
it should help i was i was a little bit
struck by
in in some of the later minute stories
so i'm up in the in the 50s now i guess
um
you get some pretty
fairly long complex sentences um
but um
you know not right away and and they
weren't too much
german has a lot more
helper words a lot more words to put the
phrase together than russian does
and as i say it worked for me and
language is as different as persian
arabic greek
so i'm just curious to hear people's
reactions if it were me if i were the
tsar i would start everybody on the mini
stories
no numbers colors names of your uncle
aunt father mother how are you post
office none of that stuff right into the
mini stories
and listen to them often read them often
and you just build up traction you build
up familiarity you gain i'm surprised
you only have 600 known words when i was
at
60 mini stories in persian or arabic i
was several thousand known words i
haven't been uh very
um
active in moving them to known
i don't know sometimes i'll click on
them but sometimes they just let them go
no but if you go through a story if you
turn the page anything you didn't click
on should register as a known word yeah
but there aren't that many words in
those many stories
i mean i did them in japanese like you
don't you don't get that many words from
i don't find really
okay anyway i don't want to monopolize
it okay so we should probably keep
moving here um
antonio how's it going maybe you you can
uh you can go next
hi everyone how are you doing hope
you're fine
um
well my name's antonio i'm from spain
we've probably
we've met before mark yeah some time ago
for sure um and yeah i've been using
link for many years probably five or six
years on and off and i've been using it
recently to improve a couple of
languages
and uh yeah i think it's a
great resource
uh
should i
should i share my screen or sure please
let us know let me show us you know
whatever you want to show how how you
use link what you find
helpful for you
well i've been using link for different
languages
for improving my english french
and italian mainly and now i'm improving
my german i started it a couple of years
ago
and
i started with the uh
with the starter manuals like teach
yourself or
assimil and
once you do that which is
i think the most boring part then you
can actually enjoy
the language
for example now i'm improving my german
with
with news
there's um there's a podcast of the um
deutsche welle
which is lang zambia
which is uh
uh
which is about the the daily news they
post it every day and you can read it
and listen to it at the same time which
is good
uh
myself i i work in
in an industry where i have to
to talk every day to a lot of clients
either by email or by phone and i try
and do these in their own languages
so if if i was about to call a german
client tomorrow it's nice to to talk
about the current news especially
coronavirus and so on so i try and
read and listen to things that interest
me and that i can find useful
and that's easy to do on link
great
all right
that um content from deutsche welle is
that that you're going you're going
there and then you're importing that
into link then i just do it with my
phone
i i do it with the app so
i just click on share and import it into
link right you've got the audio
and the text yeah yeah
yeah oh that's great yeah deutsch
developments lots of great great content
for sure if anything especially
especially the news but you you need to
have a base to to understand it because
if not you'll have too many words that
you don't understand
so that comes after a couple of months
of
right of study
yeah i i might comment here uh
i think what's important in what antonio
is saying is that if we can get into
content that is interesting
and sometimes can be difficult as you
say you need to have enough words
otherwise it's a bit of an uphill
struggle i'm kind of in that situation
right now with my arabic and persian
that the news podcasts which someone
transcribes for me are still just like
too much hard work
uh so at least in the persian i have
this person giving me a simplified
history of iran which we have on our
persian section which is really
excellent i just love going through it
the arabic
i like our news feed at link because
sometimes i get bored with my
arabic podcast and so i just i wonder
what other people are studying i go to
the news feed and i found this really
neat stuff uh something about
education in in you know levantine it's
in sort of a mixture of standard arabic
and levantine arabic and education in
jordan and stuff like that
and so i'm working my way through that
and and then i suddenly realized you
know i don't have the impression that
i'm making any progress
it seems that it's always difficult for
me
and i'm i'm putting in an hour a day of
listening and i'm putting in another 45
minutes or so of fighting my way through
these things varying levels of
difficulty the iranian history is really
interesting but i know in my heart of
hearts that i'm improving and i think
one of the messages and i'm sure antonio
and you will all agree we have to be
patient like we just have to continue
doing it we listened a bit here we work
our way through some texts there
slowly we're adding to our known words
total we're we are improving we're
putting if we're putting in that hour
hour and a half a day we are improving
even though it seems at times as if
we're not and that's where it's really
useful to get either interesting stuff
like deutsche weller for news or finding
something new on our feed
so that we don't get bored because we
just have to stay the course that was
would be my one comment
and i found out i've actually found news
really interesting
i've been doing this actively for a
month so in the beginning there were
many words that i didn't understand at
all especially
in the last month everyone's speaking
about coronavirus every day so
after two or three weeks you come across
all these words that you didn't know at
the beginning
maybe written in a different forum in a
different tens
but you start
remembering those words the news are
actually
quite good if you if you do that on a
daily basis
especially if you're in sort of a
similar topic if you're seeing articles
about a similar topic that's a great way
to reinforce the
vocabulary i know i've been reading news
articles in japanese and i find
news tough in japanese because
it's more sort of word dense i guess and
lots of kanji lots of kanji and and
it's you can't you have there's the only
way to learn words in japanese pretty
much is to see them and see them and see
them because you can't read them if
you've never seen them before more or
less i mean you have to see them and
understand what they mean
so you end up it's very word dense and
and it's work but you get better
especially if you can find
related articles with with similar
vocabulary but it's
definitely a challenge when you first
start getting into into news about
serious topics and
anyway it's it compared to say italian
that where you get a lot of cognates i
think it's
ken was pointing out with german that's
uh it's a challenge for sure
um
yeah great uh any anything else to add
to antonio
well um if you want i can share i can
quickly share my screen to
what i've been doing
can you see the screen yep
all right so that's what i've been doing
in german if you see
on my lessons
uh
quick imports
quick inputs is the thing i use the most
because you can just
find whatever you want
so
this is a really
interesting source so you see
today's news i've already done that they
they post it every day and then you can
then you can look for other ones
i've used link for other languages as
well
and i've come to
let's say
well in german i've learned 14 000 words
which is
i think it's still not enough to be
completely professional in german but in
other languages like i don't know
english or italian or french that's more
than enough
so you can actually keep track of what
you're doing here
and
what i've actually found interesting
i've been using it for several years and
link has been growing
um the community and the challenges that
you've been
setting are quite interesting because
you can
you can see what other people are doing
it's in spanish by the way
uh these are challenges
so you can you can see what what other
people in the same situation as you are
doing and and i think
um
one of my friends was developing another
app for learning languages and he found
out
with a massive survey that people
without a community
don't actually learn the same way so
that i think that's a really positive
thing that you did
with the challenges
great
yeah i mean everything we can do to kind
of every little thing we do to try and
motivate people in different ways all
just kind of contributes to keeping
people motivated i mean
we'd like it that everybody was
perpetually self-motivated but
we know that
external motivation can help just keep
people going and
and if we keep going as as steve said
just put the time and you know if you're
doing what
you do on link you you'll you're getting
better even though sometimes you may not
feel you are you are your vocabulary is
increasing and your familiarity is
increasing
um yeah okay well antonio thanks very
much
thank you uh maybe we'll
switch to and and let's hear from jade
now jade nice to meet you
uh yeah
hey nice to meet you too
uh yeah so i'm still quite a newbie on
linked
so i will try to
share with you how i use it or how i've
been using it so far so
how you can as you can hear from my
accent i'm from the south of france so
uh
so up if my internet will allow me to
share my
screen up
can you see it
yeah looks like it's coming
okay good
so
i'm
right now i'm tackling like swedish and
spanish
so
i've been
mainly using songs
so
i
like imports like thanks to clara in one
of your previous gatherings that shares
a great website
zero to europe
so i've been reporting songs that i
break down the lyrics with
link and
when i start to feel confident and since
like
the in the chorus the words tend to
repeat themselves and
quite often so i tend to absorb them
quite quickly so then i i try
after some time to
sing along so i'm a terrible singer but
i try it anyway i think it's a good
gymnastic
to
for your mouth and your tongue to
practice trying to follow sing-along
songs
in foreign language in your
target language
so that's what i've been using songs
mainly
for
and
then
for
the ministeries
i enjoy listening to the audio first
without without reading the text
and since i
look
i tend to get
distracted quite quite easily like
uh
if i just i'm just listening to an audio
i will be like something is happening
somewhere so i will get distracted quite
easily so i try to do
stuff while i'm listening so what i do
is i take notes so i try to
listen to words
that i recognize write them down
and then when i switch to the text or
link
i will read the text and while i'm
reading i will check if i got any of the
words right
and if i spell them correctly
and
sometimes i feel proud of myself and
sometimes i'm just like
and yes that's the main ways i've been
using like so far so through i'll try to
trick my brand to think i'm
not really working so
i find it more fun and i think it's for
me it's a trick because i have like big
trauma from school like
classes in language so i try to track my
brain to think i'm not studying a
language but like playing so it's fun at
least for me but
those ways are working for me so far so
yeah great
yeah that sounds like
like a yeah as you say a fun way
listening to songs and
uh are you are you gonna sing for us
today
i will spell you the massacre
can i ask you a question
yeah sure in the mini stories are you
using them for both spanish and swedish
yeah
and when you started with them were you
a beginner in both spanish and swedish
in swedish yep i started from zero so
so first i
i listened like to quite a lot of
audio
and
read a little bit before getting into
the ministeries and
so i had like
maybe 100 words of vocabulary
already
in my brain
and then i started to try to work on my
writing and listening and writing at the
same time to
yeah because as a french speaker of
course spanish will have a lot of
similar vocabulary so
the reading is not so very difficult but
swedish is quite different
so i'm just curious be and and the
pronunciation in swedish is not that
easy pronunciation in spanish is quite
easy
so
i'm just curious again i asked this
question because i want to understand
how difficult people find it to use the
mini stories
as a place to begin
you know i find it okay for languages
like greek uh you know whatever arabic
person but then i'm used to doing to
learning in this way i'm just wondering
how difficult you found it
yeah sure so especially in french
because there's a lot of h sounds in
swedish and english too and in french we
just ignore the h so
i think it's a the main trigger i had
with swedish is a lot of
sounds that are made from a couple of
letters together that with my strange
sound that doesn't seem logical in
french
so first i work on that like
i did some maths like
this letter together
of its
these powers follows it will sound like
that
and then i try to
by listening to write them down to
yeah kind of
see if there was a pattern like
and but then i quickly got
i think since he's like quite close to
english in some kind of way
i
i quickly
got into it and
i find it not so difficult to understand
speaking is another issue but
understanding and getting the words
not so much
you know you mentioned speaking uh
people sometimes say well how do you get
to output because at link we tend to
stress input
although i have started speaking now
more with our tutors we have some good
tutors in both persian and arabic on
link
so i hadn't spoken with my iranian
friend who's creating content for us
at least six months
all i've been doing is listening and
reading
and when i had my first lesson with her
last week she was amazed at how much i
had improved and similarly with my
arabic tutor so it's just to remind
people that
you know it's nice to have a tutor
session i recommend it you know
depending on one's level once or twice a
week whatever
but even if you don't have that if
you're continuing to do the listening
and reading
you are in fact improving at least your
potential
in the language because you're becoming
more familiar with the language you're
acquiring more words when you start up
speaking again you actually and i have
found i end up further ahead than where
i was even though i haven't spoken for a
long time so it's just that the the
input and yeah and especially the many
stories because it's all a lot of basic
structure basic vocabulary it really
does jumpstart your speaking in my
experience but that may not be
everyone's experience
yeah yeah and once you've accumulated
like uh quite a strong passive
vocabulary i think it's easier
after to just use it and it feel like
and that's what i use that's why i use
songs because
a lot of songs and especially when
you're born and raised in a monolingual
family yeah you not used to make certain
sounds and certain muscle
around your mouth and not working at all
like i
i i think about antonio because spanish
has struggled so much with uh el laire
it's my one of the biggest trauma in in
spanish so i'm trying to by singing
along with songs i'm trying to wrap my
muscle up
and
to yeah
work on that uh-huh
one other comment that before i forget
you said when you listen you tend to
your mind wanders and it's difficult to
focus so you try to write down the words
that you hear just to force yourself to
pay attention
and i don't do that but i do agree that
if you just if you sit down saying i'm
going to sit down and listen
i think it's very difficult not to have
your mind wander
very difficult
that's why my i have a different
approach than you do my approach is i
have to be doing something else
if i'm doing something else the dishes
cleaning up
i'm running and so then you don't mind
if the mind wanders a little bit
because in a way you're getting that
learning for free because you're
actually doing something else
and i find that doing something else at
the same time i actually concentrate
better than if i were and i never i
can't do it anymore sit down oh now i'm
gonna listen to this language i can't
i don't know why that is
maybe i i feel i should be doing
something else but i think it is
important that sometimes people think
listening is i'm going to listen to this
lesson i'm going to listen to it 10
times in a row and i'm going to listen
to it until i understand it and that
really i don't think works that well
because if you're listening listening to
the same lesson over and over and over
again the brain is learning less and
less so at the very least you should go
lesson one two three four five back to
lesson one but it it could be useful to
do something else as well write down the
odd word
do the dishes whatever you're able to do
at the same time but just sitting there
listening hoping that you're going to
pound that language into your brain may
not be so efficient at least that's been
my experience yeah same for me same for
me
yeah for sure i definitely
do my listening as well when i'm doing
other things and i
def obviously
going in and out sometimes not listening
for a long stretch as i daydream about
something else or
and now it went back to oh some
piece of content grabs my attention
again and listen for a while and i think
that's natural i don't know if for every
if that means for every hour of
listening you're actually only
getting half an hour of real sort of
listening benefit i don't really know
but it's you end up doing far more
listening so that
probably the the benefit is still
significant obviously
i mean it is so anyway it's just
interesting
by the way i was going to say it's a
good thing i didn't wear my uh my red
plaid shirt
or people wouldn't be able to tell ken
apart from me you know
[Laughter]
when when i
was looking for russian learning
resources a few years ago and i was you
know looking at different things showing
up on
searches on the internet i came across
this guy speaking russian who looked a
little bit like me
peaked my interest and
found out he had a whole system for
learning it so
that's great where you're in the state
somewhere i guess uh i can't yeah i'm in
the midwest okay okay
yeah well great
thanks jade
great presentation thank you all
super interesting i think we have quite
a few questions here so maybe we can
we can move on to the questions
um
someone is asking ken how many russian
words do you think you need to count
yourself as more or less fluent i have
40 000 russian words and i am far from
being fluent in russian
i've got over 65 000 now by links
account
and i always find words i don't know
i list like i said earlier i can listen
fairly easily depending on on what
the person is talking about
um
you find obviously a lot more unknown
words in literature
people's active spoken vocabularies much
smaller i started on on books um i have
many many fewer words but those books
are what got me up to where i am now
i can't really remember the number
though
whenever you feel
you know like trying something try it
see how it goes if it's too difficult
you don't have to keep up with it my uh
imported stories are full of things i
started and never finished
um
that's an interesting
interesting point i i we get that
question sort of or you can tell people
feel this compunction to finish what
they started because that's been drilled
into them from school
um and we always have to sort of retrain
people
if you start something and it's too hard
or it's too easy or you don't like it
abandon it go find something else
this book that i held up earlier laver
um
my vocabulary is much less when i
started it it helped a lot um it was a
challenge because it's set in the i
think in the 1400s during the time of
the plagues so i've set it aside i don't
feel like reading it right now
but um
it's full of
one
at times you have this he has the
speakers speaking archaic
russian
that i didn't realize that at the time i
put questions on on the forums and the
russian natives would say i have no idea
what he's talking about
and and secondly he uses a lot of
made-up words
about various things so you just need to
um you learn to recognize some of the
archaic stuff and and the made-up stuff
you just you know understand what the
context is and move on you know why i
might just chime in on that and there's
also a question asking me what my level
is in the c e f r the european framework
i i personally think we shouldn't get
too upset like if you say fluency so
what
what is fluency i think fluency is the
ability to understand what people are
saying in most situations
to be able to communicate express you
know whatever you want to say but with
mistakes
and there will always be things you
don't understand there's always things
that you can't say
and i think we have to accept a certain
level of imperfection unless we're
professional translators or something
um
you're always gonna wish you were better
than you are
and so there's always room to improve
and we just continue you know in
doing what we're doing as long as we
enjoy it
uh
first question how many words you need
to have to be fluent i think to be
fluent you have to speak a lot
so uh you know for example in my korean
i have 40 000 words i'm not fluent in
korean but with the words that i have if
i were to spend a couple of weeks in
korea i think i would very quickly get
to where you know i can comfortably hold
conversations i just haven't spoken a
lot i do have a lot of words i kind of
have the feeling that for languages like
korean or even czech
60 000 is a good number
and uh so 40 000 is not quite enough in
russian i think 60 000 is a good number
but i think you can take that 40 000 and
and push yourself to fluency if you have
lots of opportunity to speak so if
you're in russia you're surrounded by
russians you're speaking russian even
that 40 000 word level is going to be
good enough but if you're back away from
russia you could be in wherever you know
germany or brazil or somewhere
that's i think you need to push it up to
60 000 because if you're going to talk
to russian speakers you're going to do
it once or twice a week on
on the internet that's not a lot of
exposure so if you take your 40 000
level plunk yourself into russia
surrounded by russians you'd very
quickly get the fluent in my opinion
um
but i see like with check i felt 60 000
was where i started to feel comfortable
even at 40 000 there's so much that i
don't understand when i listen i had
this series i was listening to in czech
history and stuff and this just i
listened to and it's just not quite i'm
just not quite getting it at 40 000 but
at 60 000 i was getting it all like and
in russian my uh word level on link is
90 000. now there's literally nothing
that i hear on russian that i don't
understand
so
um you know if whatever it might be i
understand it i understand the movies i
understand but i'm at 90 000. but i can
remember so long that you know i used to
go to echo mysq which isn't popular
among certain people in russia but it's
a tremendous website for russian because
every day they have like 10 or 15
interviews with both audio and text so
you that's just great content i was i
would get four or five interviews every
day in the you know in the morning that
i would listen to during the day and
then i would go and work them on link in
the evening and it just took forever
before i could really understand those
interviews and so i was at 40 000 and i
still couldn't quite understand them
i think 60 000 and of course the word
count varies the significance varies
from language to language so in korean
or slavic languages your word count
looks like it's you know
somewhat uh you know
exaggerated in some other languages
maybe you reach that same level at 30
000
but as for my level on the cefr the
question is so undoubtedly i would be
marked down in any russian test because
of the number of mistakes that i make on
case endings on on verbs of motion all
this kind of stuff i'm hitting it
whatever my 30 60 70 80 but i'm making
mistakes so presumably that would you
know mark me down however
i can sit in any conversation i
understand what everyone is saying and i
have no difficulty difficulty expressing
myself i was on tv in kiev speaking both
russian and ukrainian and there was a
big audience and i was being asked
questions and i didn't have the
slightest concern that i wouldn't
understand and wouldn't be able to
answer but i know that i made mistakes
so where does that put me i think i'm
probably a b2
on the european framework
okay we have a couple questions related
to review
uh mr helping could you explain how to
use the anki app to improve english
vocabulary i'd like to know how you use
the app
i mean how you make front side backside
on flashcards obviously you i'll let you
answer
i don't use the anki app
i'm not sure why this person thinks you
do but
i don't use the yankee app
or any other i don't even do much flash
guarding on link
for the simple reason that uh you know
even in arabic i have 11 000
uh
i think i have 11 000 known words but i
have over 30 000 saved links in arabic
so how much time would i have to spend
on anki
reviewing those 30 000 links words
phrases that i have saved i mean i only
have like i have an hour a day which is
listening and that's sort of while i'm
doing other things so that's free time
in other words it doesn't i don't have
to dedicate myself to language i just
listen now i have another half hour 45
minutes to spend am i going to spend
that reading on my ipad learning about
the history of iran learning about
political of coronavirus in uh you know
the arab world
or am i going to spend it going through
flash cards
so i don't care how efficient the anki
algorithm is i'm not going to spend my
time doing that so i have that's i don't
use it for that reason it's not where i
choose to spend my time
and the reality is you'll never you know
if you're talking about russian where
you have 90 000 words you can't you
wouldn't get never get there using anki
in fact the efficiency where you might
think you're learning better using a
review tool like or our own srs in fact
if you want to learn a large number of
words to to really drive your vocabulary
growth the fastest most efficient way is
by doing is by learning it in context
because
as you read along you encounter your
yellow links again you tap on them if
you don't know what they mean you look
them up that's a review every time you
see a word is an opportunity to review
it and it's just much more efficient
than
any kind of
review space repetition system anything
like that it's just not efficient and
while you're doing your in-context
review
you're listening you're reading you're
the the size of the language the
construction of the language everything
is continuing to
soak into your brain so
uh yeah we're we're not too big
for sure we don't use although some
people love it and that's great if you
love it and you can export from our
vocabulary page in the anki format and
and go for it but i i think you probably
won't
you can't possibly review enough words
that way unless you spend your whole day
at it um
is somebody related
i'm just gonna add so say in russian i
have 90 000 words
and my russian statistics on link say
that i have read over two million words
of russian just on link i've also read
away from the computer
the words that i've read on link i have
listened to
so the amount of listening that i have
done
read and listened both at the same time
while acquiring vocabulary that has
sort of conditioned my brain made my
brain more and more familiar with that
language so that i understand it and i'm
listening to these things as you said
mark in context i think that's a far
more valuable thing to do with your time
as opposed to just going through this
deck of you know isolated words or
phrases but that's just me some other
people you know look at it differently
i think you went elsewhere oh yeah
now i think you can actually do it at
the end of the lesson if you only read
one thing a day
you can do it oh i do that sometimes
yeah
but if you do extensive reading it
reaches a point in which it's too boring
it's just like a normal classroom
and
[Music]
you you you'll get used to it by reading
similar things in the future and you'll
you'll come
you'll come across
all of those words in different tenses
as well so you can compare them
but uh you you just have to sit there
all day to to review them all and
probably you you pick them up like if
you spend time doing review right away
after doing a lesson you're going to
reinforce those words and maybe you'll
learn the the words that you're
reviewing
feel like you're learning them faster
but you kind of it takes a bit of a leap
of faith to say i don't need to review
these i will see them again if they
matter
i'll just keep going moving along and uh
and and over time all of a sudden you
realize that hey i know a lot of these
yellow words i know them
without doing any dedicated review and
and like tens of thousands of yellow
words like i know all of these words
because i've seen them enough times
uh we had another question about uh
since we're on srs someone asking
or saying i hate using srs systems to
learn kanji what should i do
asking steve
well you know the kanji is the one place
where i very much used srs but that's 50
years ago i happen to have them here i
had this 1 000 little flash cards the
original flash cards
and
you know it had the stroke order
and on the back it had uh phrases using
the character and i would pick up
ten of them a day and i would write them
on the sheet of paper and then i would
write the meaning a couple columns over
and pick up another one
and i would i started at 10 a day i got
it up to 30 a day and this is spaced
repetition because as i take the meaning
and park it say three columns over
by the third uh flash card i'm coming i
run into the first one again so i have
to write it again
and and i invented srs long before
anyone knew about srs this was my
homemade system
and of course i would forget two-thirds
of whatever i learned
and uh but i just kept on doing it and
doing it to doing it plus i was reading
and uh
then after the first thousand because
there were a thousand in this this is a
fabulous this is 50 years old you know
held together by
wire but
uh so that was srs but but now there's
so many systems like uh you know i don't
know they're probably more efficient
systems
but the trouble with the characters it's
it's like it's almost yes it's meaning
yes it's but it's not like learning
words they're almost separate things
that you have to learn and i think where
srs is most effective is where you have
things that are almost divorce
divorced from any context there's no
emotion there's no connection it's just
these things you got to learn the names
of different birds or something so to
some extent starting in the characters
was a bit like that
uh but eventually as i got into more and
more meaningful content and and i would
still try and write them out by hand
when i came across new characters but i
found that to get a grip on the
characters i needed to have some kind of
a system like that but that was
constantly throwing the characters in
front of me so that i could learn them
so i that doesn't answer your question
but i i should only i'll just say though
that there are far more systems now for
learning characters and a little bit of
googling probably will help you find
them
i'd i'd be very curious to see how
someone would do just starting in on
mini stories without having done any
review on of
or or flash carding of of characters and
just the from the fact that words
reappear frequently you just start to
know what the words mean i
i have to believe that's the case
because i mean i i did some sort of
dedicated kanji learning but i certainly
have learned a lot more just by
doing lessons on link and moving through
them and seeing charac characters repeat
and
after a while what's amazing is you'll
see a character and and wow i know what
that i know that word and and like
without even trying to think about it
you just automatically kind of know that
word and
i i don't know i surprised myself
sometimes with with that with the kanji
that oh actually i know that i don't
know why i know that but i know it
because i've just seen it in enough
different situations so i think it's
also good to revise them on the um
on the vocabulary part of in in link i'm
learning chinese at the moment
so i i could basically learn 10 words a
day let's say
but i think it's useful to see the word
and the phrase below
because you can learn 10 words and not
be able to use them in a conversation i
just had a lesson a couple of days ago
in chinese and i
i although i knew
500 words i couldn't use them properly
so
i think what you said before mark is is
really important to learn words with
context because if not
it'll just be a list that you've
memorized right
uh
let's see what else we've got here um
here's a guy we're kind of on this theme
i wonder how long it usually takes
people to reach
twenty thousand thirty thousand
whatever
known words with link specifically
with chinese or japanese
i must say with with japanese it's
certainly slower going than
with
with italian for example or
you know french
because it's it's hard to acquire words
in japanese because of the
you don't get free words i mean in in in
at least as an english speaker in the in
the latin languages there's so many
similar words i can't remember what the
percentage is something like 75 percent
of english words are latin based so
once you really get going in in
in those languages you realize that you
know a lot of words even without ever
having seen them before
japanese is definitely
much a much slower pace of growth
but i i assume that you know yeah if i
just keep going doing more and more
reading um
just you just have to see the words
enough times that you that you that you
start to to learn them i am having a bit
of a challenge in japanese finding
books to read it just seems like it's
more difficult to find ebooks than to be
able to
import them and and that was my that is
my favorite method of really driving
vocabulary growth so
maybe i'll steve if you have some
comments yeah i would say of course i
haven't learned
japanese or chinese on link but if i
look at my experience with greek
where the writing system is different
and there aren't so many cognates in
greek and in particular if i look at
arabic and persian to get to 30 000
words if it's similarly if it's it may
even be more difficult in japanese and
chinese i think it's two years
it's not less than two years like it's a
long road
in those languages i mean
romanian was a piece of cake because
it's like 70 italian almost
you know
those are freebies freebie languages
once you get into the the languages
where there are very few common you know
items of vocabulary different writing
system just takes a long time
on the other hand it depends how much
time you put in daily like when i was
learning chinese
i did it seven hours a day
so
on that basis if you put in more time
every day it can be one year
but most people i think on link are
happy to to have an hour an hour or
two hours a day
so uh on that basis it's it's two years
but if you can ramp it up it's fine a
similar question i just saw someone said
uh he wants to get to he or she you know
leeroy he wants to get to c2 in russian
how many words on link
you know i i think if you want to get to
c2 on russian you got to do literature
you got to do a wide variety of content
you can't just do sort of history or
something i happen to be interested in
history because you need a wide a solid
grounding in the language and you have
to talk a lot because it's only through
a lot of speaking that you will in my
opinion
develop habits of using some of these
very difficult aspects of russian
grammar correctly so i don't speak
enough to speak accurately like i make
mistakes i don't know how many mistakes
depends on i guess
you know at different times i make more
or fewer mistakes but if i'm with people
speaking all the time and i hear them
using the language correctly i'm
gradually going to start using the
language more correctly myself so i
don't know that's yeah 80 000 words is
enough theoretically to be reached c2
but you have to do other things with
that you have to read widely and you
have to speak a lot
if i may add something
sure
yeah
i've seen like
in a lot of comments in
like uh the gathering people are like so
focused on the number of words
and i find it kind of funny maybe it's
not it's because
i don't have the same mindset regarding
learning language but
i think they're so focused on learning a
certain amount of words that they don't
at the end they don't really know how to
use like a third of them
outside of the amount like they don't
know how to use it in sentences
and i think like before
accumulated like a lot of
like vocabulary uh
input like you
really have to practice like speaking
and not just
listen or just
read a lot but also
rightly speaking a lot so even if you
have like a thousand words i would like
i i started like straight away like for
swedish to speak and it helped a lot
with
knowing how to use the words and even if
though i just have like 500 i can
already like
have a small conversation so i think
like uh
yeah i find it like kind of weird like
to focus like on how i have to get to 20
000 and stuff like that i don't know if
it's just me or
i think this is a very individual thing
uh
personally
i didn't used to start speaking until i
had eight or ten thousand words
uh because i don't like the idea that
i'm in a conversation and i don't
understand what the other person is
saying and i'm struggling to say
anything
so that hour that i spend i would rather
spend it trying to acquire more words
and more familiarity with the language
but it's very individual some people
want that they they find it stimulating
obviously you realize where you're you
know what you're lacking
but me and now with the mini stories
i've started speaking after 3 000 words
that's a major change in my
strategy but even at that i speak once
or twice a week so speaking once or
twice a week at most is not going to
have as big an impact on your learning
as the hour or two a day that you're
spending with the language so i
i think that is is very personal it's
entirely up to what people like to do
but my own
sense is that
obviously your passive vocabulary is
going to be much larger than your active
vocabulary
and it's a good thing that it is because
you have to try to understand what the
other person is saying
comprehension is the it's the core if
you don't understand what the other
person is saying
you can't have a conversation
if you understand what the other person
is saying and you have some difficulty
in saying what you want to say that's
still a conversation
but if you don't understand what the
other person is saying and you keep on
saying i beg your pardon could you
repeat that
that's not
for me it's not comfortable so
but it's very personal
and as i say with the many stories i
find that i have more verbs i have more
momentum i can get started earlier
and
engage with a tutor once or twice a week
maybe
uh
but the idea that we have a lot of words
that are in our passive vocabulary that
we don't use that's absolutely normal
uh
it has to be the native speaker has been
exposed to the language since early
childhood they will always have a larger
vocabulary than we have and i want to be
able to understand what they're saying
and then i have to fit what i have to
say around my much more limited
vocabulary but as i gain confidence you
know if i understand more and i start
using the language more gradually
some of my passive vocabulary will
activate but it'll always be
a much smaller
uh
set of words and phrases than my passive
vocabulary and and i think that's a good
thing
we have one a user says
one day i created 700 plus links yet
accumulated only 200 plus known words is
that a healthy predictable accrual of
known words link members tell me my
numbers are the opposite of what they
should be
in my experience it depends entirely on
the language
if you are doing spanish
and particularly if you know another
romance language
then
the known word there will be
fewer links and more known words
accumulating
because you will find uh you know on a
page or in a lesson that might have 500
words you'll find 50 words that you
didn't know
but 450 words that are so similar to
words that you know in other languages
that
bingo you got 450 known words
in arabic
every word is new you know every word is
strange
you're not getting any freebies so the
known words total and i tend
not to go into my list of created links
and deliberately try to move them to
known
over time gradually i've seen it often
enough that okay i know this word so the
known words in the more difficult
languages languages where there are
fewer items of common vocabulary the
known words accumulate more slowly and
you're creating more links
i think that's normal so it depends on
the language
yeah i've definitely found that and by
the way 700 links in one day that's
pretty good
pretty good
certainly in japanese it's it'd be a
similar ratio for me way more links
created then known words accumulated and
that certain in italian for sure was the
reverse as you say especially once you
kind of hit your stride you're there's
just so many free words that you're
getting all these known words all the
time so definitely depends on the length
i think it depends also on the learner
itself because even though you may
recognize a word there are people who
actually highlight it just in case
because they want to know how to write
it or how to spell it
and then they'll
they'll put it as known a couple of
weeks later that's a good point there
are people that are also a little bit
reluctant to claim words as known
because they're not a hundred percent
sure that they know it
and uh i mean i and that's personal
preference too but i certainly like if i
think i know it it's good enough if i
don't know it the next time i see it
then i'll click on it and make it a link
there's no real
i think one of the big messages for link
is that
we want you to be relaxed it doesn't
it's not that crucial to be so accurate
in your in your in your
known words like if you think you know
it you probably do good enough move on
yeah i i tend to go both ways i'll get
make it known because yeah good enough i
don't totally understand or at other
times i'll say hey this is a word i
wouldn't mind having another look at i
should keep this in focus so i leave it
as as you know a category two or
category three or sometimes i'll collect
a phrase around it and keep the phrase
for a while and then i'll
get rid of that phrase that's a bit like
how ken keeps his phrases around which i
do as well i keep my phrases around
because i'd like to be able to
say it that way the way they put those
words together even though i understand
the words i know the words i'll keep the
phrase link
like ken does for sure when i'm reading
something in russian that i'm really
enjoying and understand pretty well i'll
just keep turning the page and those
blue ones will go to known
even if without me stopping to think
about them
and sometimes i'll come up
to them again in a different context it
won't be so clear i'll move them back
down now whereas in german just starting
out trying to learn enough
to have a context to understand words
and i'm much more careful and deliberate
uh let's see i'm currently a b1 in
portuguese i'm going to brazil for two
and a half months and will only speak
portuguese is a b2 a possibility got any
tips to get there
i'm currently doing link every day
uh
yeah my advice is uh first of all if you
can afford a uber or taxi in brazil
those are the your best language
teachers
uh
they like to talk you hardly even have
to get them going
and it's just a lot of talking what you
need to do is have a lot of speaking
practice you know you've done a lot of
listening and reading now through link
your big opportunity in brazil is to
speak so you just got to speak as much
as you can the brazilians are so
friendly so outgoing
you shouldn't have any difficulty
finding people to talk to but if you're
uh
if you haven't got anyone to talk to
call an uber or a taxi and you'll get 30
minutes of free portuguese lessons and
get caught up on portuguese paul or at
least brazilian politics
uh here's another possibility b2 is
definitely a possibility keep on your
keep on listening and reading and just
do a lot of speaking
uh what do you think about language
acquisition for kids by immersing them
in more than one language
well i have no experience in dealing
with kids but
i think kids should just be exposed to
more than one language they don't have
to speak them correctly they don't have
to understand everything
it just makes the brain that much more
flexible they're hearing different
sounds they're hearing you know they're
following cartoons or whatever in
different languages i think that it's
just good for them
you know sweden they can all speak
english because they watch so much
english language television and they
probably understand 20 30 eventually 50
so i just think it's good i think
there's far too much emphasis with kids
on teaching them and it's perhaps
generally true teaching them a language
with the idea of making them use it
correctly and you know asking them you
know listening comprehension questions
and trying to like they understood 50
that's okay you know they got it wrong
it's okay expose kids to the language
two or three more i think that's good
that's my view
uh steve mark do you appreciate requests
for adding languages to link or does it
get annoying slash overwhelming that's
uh
i mean we get obviously we get a lot of
requests for all manner of languages all
the time um
yeah the the reality is we're we can't
add all languages all the time um
we at some level we would like to have
as many languages as we can possibly
have but obviously it takes
time and effort and resources to even
set up a language nevermind to try and
populate it with content a big issue
with
setting up languages and not really
having content is that users who come
along and want to study those languages
and
who don't find much in the way of
content blame us for that even though
we're only responding to user requests
to add it with with limited content so
we've taken the position that unless we
we have a
you know at least this 60 mini stories
and ideally some more content we're not
we're not going to add languages but
that if if those are created then we
will try to add those languages uh
when we
when we can um
we're obviously
always doing lots of different things
and trying to improve the product and
the reality is that the overwhelming
majority of users are are not studying
like whatever languages we have now the
overwhelming majority users are are
are are using like we've got most of it
covered in terms of volume of learners
but obviously the niche languages the
smaller languages or the less popular
languages we would like to have them too
but they're they're uh i don't know if
that answers your question i i don't
know if annoying or overwhelming but
there it's just reality we can only add
a limited number and we want to have a
certain amount of content there before
we do
you know the i tend to be
always keen to add languages so
apparently someone did the 60 mini
stories in georgian so we're going to
add georgian
we'll have one or two people
at most learn georgian
i see this in persian i was very keen to
get persian
mark didn't want it but i wanted it
because i was doing arabic so with my
arabic script i want to do persian
and there's lots of persian speakers
here in vancouver lots of immigrants
from iran
and so that we did the many stories and
then i've been uh paying this person in
iran a to transcribe podcast we got
permission from a podcaster and b she's
been doing this iranian history series
which is excellent i think we have
perhaps one of the best sources of
persian learning content on the internet
and i know because i have searched the
internet
and and it's phenomenal what we got and
so then i go and look at how many people
are studying this content
that we've now paid for and it's great
content and we're talking about five ten
so
you know it's a bit frustrating so
there's great enthusiasm yeah we should
have tagalog we should have thai we
should have persian we should have
georgian and then we go to a lot of
trouble and we create the ministers
other people volunteered to produce this
stuff and even the mini stories once
you're done with the mini stories okay
now where do i go i want to do something
else so then we said okay let's invest
in getting some other content up there
and there's just not that many people
who study it so
mark's job is to run link i'm the guy
who likes to dabble in languages but
mark's job is to run linc so he says
we're up
and
what we're doing now in terms of
improvements at lincoln which i'm
testing in beta it is phenomenal but
it's a lot of work and doesn't want to
be distracted by adding georgian and
whatever estonian
other language just because
i want to learn them so probably my
answer to your question is yes
at the same time we do want to support
all languages so i think over time
ideally we we we have the ability to add
more and more but it will always be at a
limited cadence it's not going to be
we're never going to add 100 languages
all at once and
try to be offer the most languages of
any site and i should add there are
always issues with each language okay
the dictionary then someone says that
dictionary is no good can you add this
other dictionary so in persian for
example we don't get text-to-speech so i
bug mark how can i get text-to-speech in
persian we got text to speech in arabic
so he goes around searching for
different text-to-speech providers that
might have persian so that's work to be
done and now it turns out that with
persian but not in arabic when we import
items some of the
text gets squished and you can no longer
create links this happens
every third or fourth item that we bring
in so now we've got to research into why
does that happen for persian so there is
no language that's just trouble free
turn it on there's always issues so i
understand why mark is reluctant i don't
admit that to him but it's true
yeah
um i think we still have more questions
but we have been that we've been going
for a while here so i think um we'll
call it uh we'll call it for today and
um we we are doing this every week so
please keep your questions and
and uh i come back next week and and uh
ask them again uh we very much
appreciate uh your time jade ken antonio
that was that was tremendous uh i know
that uh
both
steve and i and those of us at lincoln
all the rest of our members watching
watching at home uh i find it very
interesting to see
how
our members use link and and uh just
different perspectives i think i think
these are really fun to do the the
gatherings and
and keep safe clear your masks wash your
hands
absolutely
okay bye everybody bye again bye
bye